the beyonders back ladies and gentlemen
and that's not even the main thing that
happens in this story this story is
crazy or at least this issue is crazy
right so here's what this does this
initially opens up with the Avengers
facing off against a guy named the
autocrat he doesn't matter he's
ultimately defeated by She-Hulk whatever
who cares the thing about this is this
story takes place immediately after the
events of all-out Avengers we didn't
cover the entirety of that because there
were only select moments in that story
that were important we'll talk more
about that later on when we get to the
main villain that's being introduced
here who's basically the new God of
Marvel Comics it's crazy but what ends
up happening is that once the auto crowd
is overtaken The Avengers are brought by
Iron Man and t'challa to a new room that
they've never seen before in Avengers
Tower and the thing about this is that
even when the Avengers say like we've
never been in this room before the
response of Iron Man and Black Panther
is neither have we now if you guys
notice there's like this kind of
monologue that's being offered right
these blue squares with white letters
that is the beyonder talking we know
that from all Avengers we know the
beyonder's back we've known that for a
while but the thing about this is he's
always kind of talking about how like
there's a main event that's taking place
something that's transpiring and what
he's been doing or had been doing during
the events of all-out Avengers is
altering reality Around The Avengers
themselves to create these weird and
wonky circumstances in the hopes of
changing their perception of the world
and kind of bringing their mind to newer
Heights so they can face off against
greater threats than they've ever
encountered before one of the things to
remember is that at the end of all-out
Avengers Captain America figured out the
beyonder was the one who had been
manipulating reality around them right
there was literally this moment where he
was standing in a room by himself and
directly addresses the beyonder because
he was seemingly the only one who had
ever done anything like this before from
Secret Wars 1 and Secret Wars 2. so the
ammo made perfect sense and So what had
happened here is Black Panther and Iron
Man had basically worked on this system
that would be able to detect an energy
source and then force that energy source
to enter into its physical form the
problem here is at any time the Avengers
came close in The all-out Avengers
storyline to figuring out that beyonder
was the one behind all this he would
alter reality around them again so they
would basically lose whatever momentum
they'd gained and so by working
separately as far as the beyonder was
concerned they were just kind of doing
individual things and working on
individual projects and he was none the
wiser secretly they were working on two
halves of the same machine and they
basically pressed a button when they
were completed and the Machine
teleported to this current location and
effectively assembled itself and then
once the beyonder realizes what's going
on it's too late the machines turned on
and the beyonder is yanked out and
pulled into a physical form now here's
the thing about this right for those of
you guys who are not not familiar with
the beyonder this guy is as close as you
get to God as anybody ever has been in
the history of Marvel Comics there's two
versions of beyonder right you have
what's called prerecon beyonder and the
modern day beyond it pre-redcon is the
level of power he had in secret Wars 1
and Secret Wars 2 before you get to the
unofficial Secret Wars 3 you'll find a
link to that playlist down in the
comments section so you can basically
see you exactly what I'm talking about
and understand the change that Marvel
made when they reduced his power but one
of the things that Jonathan Hickman had
done in Avengers and New Avengers is he
had returned both the beyonder and the
beyonders his whole race back to the
level of power they had at the beginning
of all things which is why you saw the
beyonders wiping out the cosmic entities
at the end of Jonathan Hickman's
Avengers The New Avengers run literally
it was a massacre Hank pym's just like
out in space trying to find out where
the incursions like how it's all
starting and he sees the beyonders
killing like eternity Infinity Oblivion
Master order Lord Chaos they kill the
Living Tribunal it's nuts it's one of
the most insane moments ever in the
history of the comic oh God I love that
point in Marvel Comics but the thing
about this is that once the beyonder
re-emerges he immediately panics and
starts to freak out because what he says
is you have no idea what you've done
I've been trying to help you I've been
trying to help you by putting you
through the paces through all these
crazy escapades and whatnot giving you
different levels of power or different
tools that you can use because you have
no clue what's coming it there's a
reason I've been hiding and I'm hiding
from that guy that's something to
understand here the beyonder this being
of astronomical power is hiding from
someone because there's so much more
powerful than he is that he can't even
begin to compare and that's when he
starts to spill the beans on what's
going on right he says before the
Omniverse came into being there was the
lost one The Lost One created the
beyonders much like they would later do
with me he imbued my people with the
tiniest fraction of his power he watched
with interest is my people grew jealous
and then resentful and he watched as
they plotted against him when they
attacked he allowed it curious to see
what would happen this turned out to be
a mistake realizing too late the genuine
threat they post the lost one could do
little as they stole the rest of his
power now there is something that I do
want to talk about here for a second and
that's Defenders Beyond by Al Ewing and
the reason for this is because this
story is not written by Al Ewing this is
written by Derek Landy and the reason
why that's so important is because in Al
Ewing's Defenders beyond what he stated
is that the beyonders were actually
created by the celestials so we've got
an inconsistency here now what we don't
know and this is one of the things you
just kind of have to wait and see in
Marvel Comics is which one Marvel goes
with this summer actually I think it's
in the fall one of the big things is
taking place this year is that Jonathan
Hickman is coming back to Marvel Comics
to basically write a story about
Marvel's Gods what in effect it seems
like he's gonna do is completely rework
and restructure the nature of the cosmic
hierarchy in Marvel Comics so we'll have
a definitive understanding of where
people rank in terms of the level of
power they have whose incontinuity who's
out of continuity that kind of thing so
all you can really do right now if you
are reading Marvel Comics is just kind
of take this as potentially one
possibility of where the beyonders
actually came from that neither answer
seems to be definitively right but what
is important here assuming that we take
this as an absolute truth is the
beyonders are not native to their own
source of power and this flies in the
face of everything we know about the
beyonders right so a little bit of
explanation here for those of you guys
who aren't familiar with the nature of
the beyonders their power different
things like that when the beyonder was
first introduced in Marvel Comics he was
just kind of a one-off in the secret War
Story and that was it but Secret Wars
proved to be so popular they brought him
back and then that was all we really got
right it was like the beyonder secret
Wars part two and that was it it wasn't
until you got to the Fantastic Four
story that was kind of The Unofficial
Secret Wars 3 that you learned the
beyonder is simply one member of a race
called the beyonders and they exist
beyond all space and time outside of the
Multiverse now that was kind of the
standard going forward for years there
wasn't really any indication or
reconciliation between the beyonder and
the beyonders outside of the fact that
the beyonder was part of their race and
for whatever reason was interested in
the Multiverse in Marvel Comics when
Jonathan Hickman came along in Avengers
and New Avengers what he basically said
is the original beyonder from Secret
Wars the one you see here right now this
one was like a child right a baby more
or less that had kind of been created
inadvertently when the molecule man Owen
Reese had basically conducted his
experiment and created a Cosmic Cube by
accident and in doing so half the energy
went into Owen Reese the other half went
out and became the beyonder the
beyonder's source of power was never
really explained it was always just a
level of powers that they had that made
them incredibly powerful Al Ewing and
Defenders Beyond explained that by
saying their level of power was given to
them by the celestials so that if
another war broke out between the
celestials the beyonders could put the
gabash on it right and just end the
threat like that so it wouldn't lead to
the destruction of the Multiverse again
and so it's just kind of been that way
ever since this is a whole new
explanation right the fact that there is
a singular being out there who had such
an astronomical level of power that the
beyonders stole that power from him and
then dispersed it among themselves and
used it for their own ends now the funny
thing about this is that as is explained
here the lost one cannot be
traditionally killed or destroyed and
seemingly any conceivable way were not
told what where somebody just told
that's the case and so they basically
imprisoned him on a moon that existed
outside the Omniverse now one of the
things that I want to explain here is
that Marvel in more recent years
Omniverse and Multiverse are just two
words to describe the same thing it
didn't used to be that way the Omniverse
used to be a collection of multiverses
and in fact the Omniverse was kind of
The Unofficial comic book explanation
for the collection of the DC Comics
Multiverse and the spawn Multiverse and
the Marvel Multiverse and any other
Multiverse that exists out there as a
giant collection of multiverses but
again in this day and age Marvel seems
to be using Multiverse and Omniverse as
interchangeable terms but of course with
him being imprisoned what ended up
happening here is somewhere along the
line he basically broke out and that
what he's been doing is traveling around
the Multiverse killing any beyonder he
finds absorbing their power into himself
or any force that the beyonders send
after him in order to try to destroy him
but the bigger point that beyonder makes
is that he and his race are just fleeing
for their lives and hiding away from
this guy as best as they possibly can so
what we thought was at one point these
astronomically powerful gods are hiding
from someone even more powerful what I'm
I'm hoping you're noticing here
particularly if you're reading Marvel as
a whole and have been for the last
couple years the entire hierarchy is
being thrown in disarray a good example
the one above all is no longer the most
powerful being in Marvel Comics anymore
we know that from Defenders Beyond right
the crown or whatever it is that he's
called the Enigma is the most powerful
being out there in Marvel right now but
the funny thing about this is that when
they ask when the Avengers ask so why
are you here the response to the
beyonder is so you can help me fight
this war and the Avengers are kind of
like what are you even talking about man
like so you're literally telling us that
there is a guy out there whose level of
power dwarfs the power of you and you
are a guy who popped up on the scene and
like killed death in our universe and
the cosmic entities had no choice but to
go to the molecule man Owen Reese and
ask him for help because they were
helpless to stop you right that took
place in the secret Wars too like you're
that guy and you think we can help you
defeat this other dude what are you
talking about man like I mean if we can
find a peaceful resolution sure I guess
but like we can't win a war against a
force like that like what could we do
harsh language you get the Infinity
Gauntlet cross our fingers and hope for
the best like I mean there's nothing we
can do here and the response to the
beyonder is simply I've given you
whatever tools you need to succeed but
in the midst of all this where he
initially allies himself with the
Avengers and says I will help you fight
this war and presumably I'll gather the
other beyonders and we will try to do
the same they're suddenly met by the
arrival of tiamak now here's the thing
tiamak was introduced in all out
Avengers issue number four but the
reason why I didn't cover it at the time
is because it didn't seem to serve a
real purpose the only thing that
happened is like tiamox showed up and
beat the crap out of Carol Danvers which
was kind of amazing to see but all we
saw with her was that like at the end of
the comic she had approached just this
crazy wild looking dude who of course we
now know to be the lost one and like
that was it there was no context to the
situation so it just didn't really make
any any sense to cover it at the time
but the idea behind this is that tiamok
is basically an emissary of the lost one
as it was explained in Avengers Beyond
number four she's like his right hand
right so like his top person that he
basically sends out but the funny thing
about this is that Thor stands to her
alongside Carol Danvers and this girl
crushes them both this is what's so wild
about this right under any normal
circumstance a villain showing up and
facing off against the Avengers I mean
it's cool and you get to see like a bit
of a battle this girl is not even really
a battle so much as Child's Play right
it's her just kind of keeping herself
entertained at the moment this chick
isn't even really trying but she
single-handedly crushing the entirety of
the Avengers by herself but ultimately
she ends up achieving her goal and this
happens when she pulls a dagger and is
able to cut the beyonder and when that
happens as he bleeds she says it's done
that because of her actions here that
basically injuring him his blood has now
spilled in the Physical Realm which
means now she literally says if you use
your powers in any way right if you
leave this planet's atmosphere he will
know he will know exactly where you're
at so the best thing you can do here is
to stay and hide now this may seem
arbitrary it may seem like Derek Landy
is kind of pulling this out nowhere this
is actually not true he's borrowing a
page out of the old silver comics from
back in the day and anybody who's
familiar with Marvel Comics would tell
you that so for those of you guys who
don't know in the original Galactus
Trilogy in the Fantastic Four when
Galactus first popped up at the end of
the story The Silver Surfer actually
turned against him and so what it did is
it forced Galactus or at least drove
Galactus to imprison the Silver Surfer
on Earth and what it did is that kicked
off the Silver Surfer solo Series where
he was basically traveling around the
world working alongside different
superheroes learning about Humanity
different things like that it was a
resoundingly successful and even to this
day still holds up as a phenomenal comic
book it's amazing but this is where
Derek Landy is getting this from right
quite literally Beyond her is made a
prisoner of Earth more so than that and
kind of what feeds into the plot he
can't necessarily use his powers but he
can't say okay well then I'll snap my
fingers and I'll help you guys defeat
this guy and we'll call together all the
different ones so on and so forth
instead he has to go back to his
incorporeal form and just kind of remain
in hiding at different places on Earth
and that's it because the instant he
leaves that's all the there is to it now
where tiamak is locked up by the
Avengers and basically put inside of a
prison that'll basically hold her the
main concern The Avengers have now is
what's going to happen if this guy sends
more forces after us and that's exactly
what he's doing specifically the lost
one is sending a reformed and presumably
cosmically Amplified version of the call
obsidian supergiant black dwarf the
ebony maw corvus glaive these guys are
all coming after him so it's gonna be
kind of amazing but with that being said
we're gonna bring this video to an end
let me know what you guys think down in
the comment section I'm loving this
story so far and I will catch you all
later peace